لم يكن نور صبري الوحيد من مشاهير العراق
الذي تعرض لحمله تنمر بسبب نشره صورته مع
ابنته الاعلامي العراقي عماد الخفاجي هو
الاخر تعرض قبل سنوات من الان الى حمله
مشابهه ولذلك اعلن الخفاجي تضامنه مع نور
صبري وابنته كذلك الشاعره العراقيه شهد
الشمري تعرضت لحمله مشابهه بعد نشر مجموعه
مقاطع فيديو مع عن ميلاد ابنتها ناي
وانتقدت كثيرا بسبب ذلك في موقف سابق تعرض
سفير العراق في الاردن الى هجمه غريبه بعد
نشر صوره هو وزوجته مع الفنان راغب علامه
وفي النهايه هذه الحالات مكرره لكنها لا
تعبر عن اغلب المجتمع انما هي لاشخاص
يتناسون ان الشخص المشهور هو انسان على كل
حال ويضعونه دائما تحت مجهرهم ليتجه الامر
من انتقاد لاعماله الى حملات تنمر حول
حياته الشخصيه